so much easier now that I can read
lightning-round boys against girls there
is no question about it Olaf you
definitely stole the show in frozen -
you're seriously the cutest and smartest
snowman ever we love all your
philosophical questions and we loved
your song about growing up and all your
random facts but the best part was when
you told the North Aldrin and the
arendelle soldier is all about the first
movie your reenactment had us fracking
Olaf and simply adored the post-credit
scene of frozen - it wasn't just funny
though keep watching to find out what
the post-credits scene revealed about
Olaf and Elsa's magic the post-credits
scene after the credits Disney surprised
fans with a really cute post-credit
scene and it was all about everyone's
favorite snowman Olaf earlier in the
movie Olaf did a hilarious reenactment
of the first frozen film at first the
North aldrin and soldiers were totally
freaked out by the talking snowman doing
performance art but as well I've got
more dramatic in his interpretation they
got super into it
general Matthias was especially invested
in the story we cracked up at Olaf's
little play and Mattias is sincere
reactions he got everyone caught up on
what Elsa and Anna were doing in the
enchanted forest the movie's creators
knew the scene would be a huge hit so
they made the post-credits scene similar
in this one Olaf acts out the events of
the entire second movie it's so funny
he mimes the whole thing and uses the
same dramatic language he's also really
clear about reminding his audience that
he was right all along
water has memory is a big theme of the
movie he first says it when he's
rattling off facts on their journey
north then when the ice memories appear
in the forest Anna asks him to explain
water is always recycled and it collects
memories in the post-credits scene Olaf
explains that's how he was able to come
back to life he's a snowman after all
and snow is just frozen water he ends
his performance by telling the audience
I live and so do you then the screen
switches to his captive audience we see
hundreds of baby snowmen marshmallow the
snow monster from the first frozen is
also there the baby snowmen were from
frozen fever in this short Elsa gets
sick
time she sneezes more little snowmen pop
out by having these magical frozen
creatures at the end of frozen to the
creator's tide all the movies together
this might suggest that the frozen
franchise is really over since it tied
up loose ends
after all lots of fans wondered about
what happened to marshmallow it was also
a great way to end the movie on a
light-hearted note the messages of
frozen - were really serious parts got
really dark even with the happy ending
it was a heavy movie but the post credit
scene lightens the mood keep watching to
find out what is revealed about Elsa's
magic what this means for Olaf oh how I
wish this could last forever and yet
change mocks us with her beauty Olaf
spends a lot of the movie worrying about
change and growing up but the post
credit scene proves that he's maturing
Olaf was technically the first creature
created by Elsa's magic they imagined
him as a child
he appeared as an effect of Elsa letting
it go in the first movie marshmallow
came next and then the baby snowmen Olaf
has developed more consciousness than
the others because he's older he's also
around humans all the time
Olaf appears to be a father-like figure
to these other snow creatures or maybe a
big brother they seemed to really
respect him and look up to him what this
means about Elsa's magic we learned in
frozen to that Olaf is linked to Elsa's
magic as the fifth spirit when Elsa
freezes or laughs flurries away Elsa
spirit nature is what keeps him alive
that means that she's even more powerful
than the other spirits she can literally
create life and she doesn't always do it
intentionally that's a huge
responsibility for Elsa it was important
that Olaf reassured them that they are
really alive because he's alive this
also means that they probably
disappeared when Elsa froze to what this
means for the snow creatures it's not
clear where these snow creatures are for
the rest of the year did Elsa give all
of them permafrost like she did Olaf or
maybe they just hang out in the
mountains where it's always cold they
could also disappear when the snow melts
and reformed the next year because water
has memory it's also possible that
they'll become just as advanced as Olaf
they're still growing and they don't
hang out
with Elsa Anna and Kristoff all the time
well marshmallow learn to read and play
charades that would be a hilarious do
you love theories about frozen - and
other Disney films then you'll love the
things click that big red subscribe
button for more awesome content and
click the bell to stay in the loop if
you're watching on a mobile device click
your settings and turn on notifications
what was your favorite Olaf moment in
frozen - don't be shy let us know in the
comment section thanks for watching
show Olaf some love by clicking that
thumbs up button see you next time